I want to mention a quick thing right
here drop the show I recently launched
my own podcast called Conan O'Brien
needs a friend a lot of fun I really
love doing it well I'm very excited to
announce that tomorrow we're launching a
second weekly podcast called inside cone
and it sounds disgusting my doctor does
this one no it's inside cone an
important Hollywood podcast yes that's
the that's the I know I love that
actually the podcast takes listeners
behind the scenes here at the show Conan
is hosted by two of our hilarious
veteran writers Mike Sweeney Jesse
Gaskell and they do interviews with
other writers and staff members and they
get sort of the I'd say the dark
underbelly of this show oh good yeah my
favorite part yeah you'll find all about
Andy's murders anyway be sure to check
it out be sure to check it out and
subscribe at Apple podcast.com slash
inside Conan or wherever you get your
podcast I think you might enjoy it if
you like the other podcast